اذا كان مركز الزلزال شديد القوه في قاع
البحار فانه يدفع بامواج سنن مدمره الى
الساحل اما اذا كانت بؤره الهزه اسفل
مناطق جبليه كهذه فان مشهد الدمار يكون
مختلفه هذا ما وقع في مرتفعات محافظه
الجيور غربيه جزيره جاوا الاندونيسيه التي
شهدت اقوى هزه ارضيه من حيث عدد الضحايا
تسجلها اندونيسيا منذ اربع سنوات
ارضيه ووقعت في اكثر من نقطه بمحافظه جور
باقليم جاوا الغربيه فدفن كثيرون تحت
الاتربه ولم يستطيع الهربه من منازلهم
خلال وقوع الزلزال وتحاول ف
رق البحر السعي الى انتشال مزيد من جهه
ضحايا من تحت الانقاض بمساعده المعدات
الثقيله ونلاحظ هنا طبيعه التربه الطينيه
التي تهدد بمزيد بانهيارات الارضيه كلما
تكررت الهزات الاعتداديه وبدرجات عاليه
الرئيس الاندلسي تفقد موقع الكارثه ووجهه
وزراهه والهيئات المختصه بالكوارث بتكثيف
جهود الاغاثه وانتشار الجثث واعانه
المتضررين
ربنا
يجب ان نلتزم بالحد الادنى من البناء الذي
يقاوم الزلزال الذي اصدرته وزاره الاشغال
العامه والاسكان وكما قالت هيئه الارصاد
فمثل هذا الزلزال يتكرر كل 20 عاما ولذلك
لابد من الالتزام بمعايير مناسبه للبناء
ويترقب مواطنون ان تتكفل الحكومه باعمار
منازلهم حسب تلك المعايير العمرانيه اذا
رصدت السلطات مبالغ ماليه تتفاوت ما بين
700$ وثلاثه الاف دولار للمتضررين ومن
بينهم السيده
لم يعد لدي ماوى كيف سيكون حالنا ليس
لدينا منزل اخر نسكن فيه انا واربعه من
اولادي وازهاري لكنني احمد الله اننا
سلمنا من الزلزال
22000 منزل فان ذلك يفسر تاثر حياه الاف
السكان بهذا الزلزال وكلهم يتطلعوا لان
يعود الى بيت يقويه لا ان يكتفي بمعونات
عينيه اما المستشفيات فما زالت تستقبل
مزيدا من المصابين من منهم في امس الحاجه
لاجراء عمليات جراحيه مستعجله صهيب جاسم
الجزيره محافظه شئ اجور اقليم جاوى
الغربيه